the lockdown must continue that was the
key message behind Prime Minister Boris
Johnson's address on Sunday as he warned
a British public to stay alert and
thanks to you we've protected our NHS
and saved many thousands of lives and so
I know you know that it would be madness
now to throw away that achievement by
allowing a second spike with the
government criticized for its slow
reaction to the outbreak opposition
members described this update as a mixed
message Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland have said their lockdown rules
will remain Johnson stressed the
importance of maintaining lockdown while
simultaneously introducing cautious mini
steps towards normality and from this
Wednesday we want to encourage people to
take more and even unlimited amounts of
outdoor exercise you can sit in the Sun
in your local park you can drive to
other destinations at the earliest by
June 1st shops would reopen and younger
pupils could head back to schools all
this only if infection rates and the
number of deaths
what's a further decrease we must
reverse rapidly the awful epidemics in
care homes and in the NHS and if were to
control this virus then we must have a
world-beating system for testing
potential victims and for tracing their
contacts with the UK continuing to
suffer the highest official death toll
in Europe it faces a long road ahead a
return to business as usual may be many
months from now well just how long is
that road DW spigot mass is with us now
from London for more at Bergen what's
going to change now can it can you give
us some clarity on that well I think
most people will be quite glad that from
Wednesday they are allowed to meet
outside there are allowed to meet a
friend keep the distance of course but
go outside more also for unlimited
exercise so I think this is what's
changing in people's private lives and
most people are will be very very
relieved about that however a bit more
controversially is
the situation around working so you have
mentioned and the piece that people are
encouraged to go to work if they can't
work from home however there is not a
lot of guidance on what exactly that
means and how are people even getting to
work when we know that we don't have a
lot in terms of public transport us
quite decrease for example here in
London not a lot of trains and buses are
running so how is that going to work in
practice
the government is saying that there will
give more details and they give more
clarity and I think this is what
especially from the unions were really
worried about this definitely is needed
ok what else have been some of the
responses that you're hearing this
criticism from the unions is everyone
waiting for later today - to get more
details yes for later today and also for
the next days and weeks we'll we'll know
more about the details of the plan
however it's really worrying that for
example Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland are not going together with
England and have been really rejecting
the Prime Minister's message so this I
think is a new development because so
far there has been UK has been moving
along as one country but now it risks
that it might be frazzled so I think
that is for the government also not not
a very welcome reaction that the leaders
of the other nations are not going with
with the UK government so the Prime
Minister will have a lot of work to do
in order to bring people on board bring
the unions on board and also work with
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland ok
he has a lot of work to bring the
regions in the UK together to get labour
on board all of this coming as the
country still faces brexit the leaving
the EU is that still on track well this
is nominally on track so Britain has
left the European Union we're now in the
so-called transition phase that ends
though at the end of the year
negotiations are underway on the future
relation
between the UK and the European Union
and it's very much hope that a trade
deal can be agreed however with the
coronavirus crisis we know that the the
focus is very much on the immediate
crisis and and not really on brexit so a
lot of people who are watching these
negotiations closely are very worried
that there is not enough progress and
that there will not be a trade deal at
the end of the year and that of course
brings economic consequences of another
magnitude to a country that's already
economically very very shaken like so
many others across the world from the
corona rise crisis so much at stake
there in the UK big at mass thanks so
much for that from London